gal it's so wonderful to meet you it's
my first time
you look beautiful thank you so much for
having me how are you i'm good you are
so kick ass and as a mother of two girls
now you have three i just want to say
thank you for everything you do you
truly inspire so many girls so you're so
sweet thank you
okay let's talk about this movie there's
that scene where you're dancing with
wayne and
uh did you give him lessons like how is
he as an actual dancer you know what i
was pretty nervous before we started and
i kept on telling dj that we gotta
rehearse and we gotta practice and we
gotta make sure we we get it
um and he was super cool and kept on
telling me don't worry don't worry it's
going to be fine
then when we started rehearsing he
he's an amazing dancer no he has such
light feet no i'm telling you it was i
was like okay i guess the days and then
you know the wrestling days he is really
good with choreographies because
he gets it in a second he was really
really good
that's amazing i'm surprised that's
that's i know i was like that's how does
the like the physics rules how could
that be that a giant man can
have such light feet but he does
and this movie's about treasure and the
biggest treasures out there what is your
biggest treasure that thing that's
priceless to you my girls my daughter is
my family
you know
yeah it's the best feeling isn't it it
really is and a lot of people are gonna
look at this movie and say wait a minute
there's wonder woman there's deadpool
there's black adam i mean if these
superheroes were to battle it out who
would win
wonder woman
of course
of course right
of course i totally agree with you of
course that's the right answer i'll ask
the other guys and see what they have to
say
and this film focuses on cleopatra and i
know you're working on your own project
how is that going and are you excited to
put it out there
yes i'm so excited it's going really
well we have a really really really
special story
um and i cannot wait to celebrate
cleopatra's
story and bring it
to life on the big screen
i love that and you know just have a
little fun you can either say the rock
or the reynolds are you ready
who's the funnier guy
reynolds
because he's so good with jokes and he
loved like his thing was to make sure he
break
you know he breaks
dj and me and
that was the biggest challenge not to
break
uh takes
that's yeah and he's canadian so it's
great uh who is a better singer
uh
they're both are pretty good singers but
i'll give one to dj do the wrong okay
yeah he's a rap song he's a rapper now
officially yeah uh who is smarter
they're both are super smart i love that
i love that congratulations on the film
it is such a great adventure and i can't
wait for rednecks too and disney of
course i can't believe you're playing a
villain but i'm so excited
thank you so much thank you you're
having the best time of your life aren't
you thank you i'm very grateful
you